I'm literally moving into college today
but I do want the experience of like
gamedays partying I don't really care
about school as you guys all know Lori
Laughlin's daughter Olivia Jade
allegedly didn't fill out her own
application to USC in a 204 page
affidavit authorities detail an email
that the actress allegedly sent to ric
singer the man who has pleaded guilty to
multiple charges and admitted to
devising the college admission cheating
scandal in which Lori and dozens of
others are allegedly implicated the
email which was allegedly sent in
December 2017 asked singer for guidance
on how to complete the formal University
of Southern California application in
the wake of her daughter's acceptance as
a recruited athlete according to the
court documents one of singers employees
allegedly filled out Olivia Jade's
application for her
according to federal prosecutors the
application was part of an elaborate
admissions cheating plan Lori and her
husband Massimo allegedly paid $500,000
to designate their daughters as recruits
on the crew team even though they don't
even row I want them to be happy so I
want to be supportive of everything they
want to do but I do want them to have
somewhat of a normal you know finish out
of high school college experience maybe
because I didn't have that I would
really want that for them both Lori and
Massimo were arrested in March on a
felony charge of conspiracy to commit
mail fraud and honest services mail
fraud when this whole cheating scandal
came out I'm not gonna say I was
surprised because for in that world kind
of just days after news of the college
admissions scandal broke one of Olivia
Jade's former classmates YouTube
lifestyle and beauty blogger Harlow
Brooks offered insight into what high
school life was like for Olivia and her
older sister Bella remember when I was
touring the school I saw a picture of
Olivia Jade's sister actually on the
wall with the seniors and it was like
congratulations I forget her name Bella
or something for getting into USC and I
was like oh wow that's crazy like USC is
super hard to get into
and then I remember hearing later that
Olivia had also gotten into USC
and I was like wow that's like kind of
crazy because USC is very extremely hard
to get into so not only one sister but
both of Harlow
opened up about the high pressure
environment students face to get into
the best colleges in the country so
there's like a network of five to seven
or so private schools in Los Angeles
that are like thirty to forty five
thousand tuition every year and the work
is literally harder than College it is
insane what these students go through to
go to these schools because their
parents think they need to because they
want them to get into Yale and Harvard
and USC she admitted that she found the
curriculum to be intense and wondered
how Olivia managed to juggle the
schoolwork with a popular YouTube
channel I'd have to get up at 6:00 every
morning and I would leave school at 4:00
and then I have like six hours at
homework it just made me think like how
is she doing this literally how does she
travel for YouTube how does she have
time to make youtube videos like an
arrangement with the school or something
like I thought it just didn't kind of
make sense to me because these schools
it's your life is literally 100 percent
school Olivia herself joked that she was
rarely at school in a video she posted
on her YouTube channel in May 20 18 I'm
like excited to go print was like
through the school prank but I'm also
literally never at school but I think my
class doesn't even and maybe they forget
I go there